yeah i got it you big guy
it's a little zap it's like hitting the
ball
holy [ __ ] oh yes
[Music]
holy [ __ ] bro
oh
[Music]
[Music]
here we are tough mudder i'm in the i
we're saying glenn helen
i don't even know where i'm at about an
hour and a half drive from the crib
walking up saw some uh thick boy some of
the thick boy nation apparently they
drink beer before they do this so i'm
drinking it's early it's 9 a.m
drinking beer
i don't know man you know burke chrysler
has like the uh he says the mickey
mantle gene have the demarcus wrestle
gym i show up i throw bombs
didn't work out for we'll see how this
goes
[Music]
yo check it out bro we are at a tough
mudder out in glen helen in san
bernardino i don't know where the [ __ ]
that was until about five minutes ago
had some difficulty getting here but
we're freaking here we got the hair up
in a man bun we're doing the damn thing
i'm the heaviest person outside of
brenden shop right in this so i'm number
two thick boy bring it up the rear we do
the damn thing kids we stop muddy as
hell all day every day never stop
stopping
[Music]
[Music]
you got a special treat coming up oh
yeah okay this is this is uh
what water and electricity combined oh
it's fantastic yeah it's gonna go good
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'll get you
i'll get you
i don't know dude i got a bad ticket
a little bit yeah
yeah i got
it's a it zap it's like
holy [ __ ] oh yes
holy [ __ ] bro
oh
oh [ __ ] that was way worse that was
that's pretty bad that's not good that's
great
i wish i'd have this fat ass i thought
it was bro i thought it was like a
little something dude that was a good
one
bro that's real
i thought there was a [ __ ] joke
oh you're going to shock you in the
water that can't be real oh it shocks
the [ __ ] out of you
it's not it's not a little sad either
it's really exactly it's just oh
bro i'm staying low that was real when i
first got in no no no no no no no no no
no no no
not a good time
dude this is way stronger i thought
supposed to be like a cutesy thing what
the [ __ ]
that was the hardest i've ever been shot
the only dangers on the on the floor on
your left
how many times do you [ __ ] be signing
up
i think we're about halfway
a little more than halfway
uh i got really [ __ ] up on the
electrocute thing i
otherwise like a little shock like maybe
a dog caller it's not
it's not
the cold plunge actually held my legs
i'm all right man i'm good it's fun
my name is greg i am
festival mc here for tough mudder
hanging out with you beautiful lovely
people we're out here on course we're
actually by blockness which is my
favorite obstacle it is a spinning block
we have to submerge yourself into water
and it's all about teamwork and
camaraderie so can you do it by yourself
yeah but it's always better to do it
with a team
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
we are champions
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
we just climbed over uh uh
a wooden thing me and braden at the same
time i was like this might not be able
to support both our weight so let's
stagger this a little bit it was a
little dicey dominated that technique
yeah
grab the hands
you're like a balance beam
in the bedroom yeah exactly you know
it's called teamwork get used
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
let's not get to navy seals by training
it's that tofu navy seal dog
[Music]
how did that feel dude
good it felt good baby
oh
oh
oh
[Music]
so funny that people think i can't
balance that [ __ ]
i have so much balance in my life
[Applause]
i was a gymnastics
[Applause]
uh
have we seen one single person jump all
the way to the top
oh yeah but i'm like there's no way i
could run up the side of it yeah it was
a frog like run up the side without
touching the rope yeah one guy
okay i've seen a lot of guys like that
fail
i'm gonna grab that room
[Applause]
let's go
right here
[Applause]
[Music]
pretty good feels like i can run for
10 hours
cramping up tad
haven't eaten today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
appreciate the fact you're an articulate
athlete oh thanks man actually yeah
speaking of trying right yeah
thanks brother i appreciate you bro
thanks man appreciate it
so i came to tough mudder i came from
union 5js
that was a bad idea so i had my new
balance running shoes in the car
but they were the woodstocks
another pretty exclusive new balance you
don't want to run those when i got here
they go dude your shoes can get
destroyed so the tough mudder gave me
these bad boys they collab with craft
shoes
and thank god they gave me these i was
able to climb mountains run hills
freaking get electrocuted get all muddy
and still keep my grip
these are the kicks of the days with
tough mudders people
okay i had no expectations going into
this tough mudder otherwise uh no just
knowing that it was gonna be wet and
dirty but this is something that i would
do again that i would recommend to other
people
you meet a lot of cool people the energy
here is unbelievable and it's something
i could see myself doing a few times a
year just to
wake myself the [ __ ] up because here i
am on a saturday morning and uh it was a
good workout it was very lively and i'm
in a fantastic mood at the end of it
despite being very exhausted and getting
the [ __ ] shocked out of me not once but
twice
that was the worst part but now i kind
of feel tough it's like you can
electrocute me
and i'm gonna still be standing at the
end of the day so come at me electricity
the electrocution thing i thought it was
going to be pretty mild not a big deal
it is not mild it is a very big deal
it's the only time i panicked i'm
panicking quite some time i literally
panicked cold ones whatever i was born
in the snow
the electric cube thing where you race
through that ain't [ __ ] the one crawling
like a god damn navy seal and you get
electrocuted
it's my only problem that's my only
problem i'm cramping i'm starving i feel
like i've earned it it's two o'clock
i've been going for about two something
hours now
they have whiskey check they got jumbo
dogs chat hawaiian shaved ice check your
boys earned it and thank god i had
somebody do it with me my boy mark did
it with me doing it solo you gotta be
you're a cereal you do this solo you're
serious this is what i want to do
in 2022 when i'm on tour maybe tough
mudder's in the same town the thick boy
nation come running with me come running
with me who's who's down i know the
electrocution thing's scary but we get
over it together we can run together so
let's figure it out i'll announce dates
we'll run together tough mudder in 2022
all right and there's mark there's my
kid who ran it my kiddo crusted little
man couldn't do it it was fun though man
that's it your boy's muddy i'm wet i'm
cramping i'm starving that's it see on
the next stop mother